同一根K线
三个人三种判断
第一个人说阳线买
第二个人说看涨吞没
符合形态买
第三个人沉默了十秒
说不碰
三个月后
第三个人是对的腿
一根K线为什么结果完全不同
答案不在经验
不在指标
不在运气
在于他第一眼落在了哪里
大多数人学K线第一件事是背形态
锤子线
十字星吞没运线背了几十个
上了实盘发现一件让人崩溃的事
同一个形态有时候涨
有时候跌
有时候原地震荡三天
很多人以为是自己没背够
继续背
甚至觉得自己态度不够虔诚
没有从天道的角度来认真学习
其实问题根本不在这里
形态没有错
是你用它的顺序错了
就像你在还没读完一整句话之前
就开始猜某个词的意思
脱离了上下文
猜到的十有八九是歪的
K线的形态
就是那个词
你跳过了前面的余景
直接开始猜
当然猜不准
那正确的顺序是什么
分三层
第一层位置拿到一张图
第一眼不是看K线
是看这根K线出现在什么地方
这是趋势运行的中段
还是来到了前高压力位的下方
是横盘震荡区间的边缘
还是一段急涨之后的高位位置
决定剧情背景
同一根阳线出现在有效突破位
是进攻信号
出现在前高压力区是风险警告
形态一模一样
含义天壤之别
很多新手在高位追进去
不是因为判断力差
是因为只看了K线
没看K线在哪里
没有位置
形态是一个孤立的词
读不出意思
第二层节奏
价格是怎么走到来
这里的连续大阳线强势推进
几乎没有回调
还是阴阴阳阳反复拉锯
磨了很久才走到这里
前者说明有持续的力量在推动
买方控场动能充足
后者说明多空势均力敌
所以就没有真正占到便宜
这种位置的突破失败率会高很多
K线的节奏告诉你的是
这段走势背后的力量结构
这是任何单一形态都没法告诉你的信息
问自己一个问题
到这里为止
谁在出力
谁在犹豫
想清楚这个问题
再去看当下这根K线
你的感受会完全不一样
第三层细节
前两层确认之后才打开这根K线本身
上影线长说明上方有人在卖价格试图上涨
但被压了回来
下影线长说明下方有人在接抛压出现
但被消化了
尸体很小
说明多空势均力敌
这根K线没有产生明确的结论
同样的细节放在不同的位置和节奏里
含义完全不同
高位出现的长上影线
是主力在出货都不会出现的
长上影线可能只是正常回踩
测试之后仍然延续方向赌细节必须有预警
没有预警
就是在拆三层
有了
接下来说怎么用
下次打开图表
按这个顺序走一遍
第一步标出当前价格所处的区域性值
是趋势运行中创建支撑压力附近
还是没有明显结构的震荡区间
这一步不需要太精确
初判断就够
目的是给自己建立一个背景框架
第二步往左数20根K线
看来路的力度是强势推进还是抹上来
中途有没有过回踩
确认亮的是放大还是萎缩
这20根K线的质量
决定了当下这根K线的可信程度
第三步再看当下这根K线的实体大小
上下影线的比例以及它和前一根的关系
此时你已经有了位置判断和解除判断
细节的解读自然会清晰很多
2分钟之内可以走完
养成习惯之后
你对图表的判断速度会快很多
更重要的是方向感会稳
不再随K线的涨跌摇摆
现在用这三步回去看开场的根K线位置
前高压地区正下方
此前刚刚完成一段急涨
期间没有任何有效回踩节奏
五根大阳线连续推进
动能看起来很强
但正因为没有回踩
透支的风险也在同步累积
细节上影线开始偏长
K线实体明显缩小
量能同步萎缩
多空博弈的主动权在悄悄转移
三个信号指向同一个结论
这里不是买入时机
是转弱预警
散户看到阳线买技术派
看到突破形态买
看懂顺序的人
看到的是位置高
节奏透支
细节转弱
三层同时亮起黄灯
选择不动
结果没有悬念
K线不难
难的是用对顺序
位置节奏细节缺任何一层结论都容易偏
而大多数亏损的交易往往不是判断方向错了
是跳过了某一层就开始行动了
下次打开图表
先问自己一个问题
这里是哪里
答完这个问题
你已经比大多数新手看的更远了